they would send me an email with an
offer I would send them an email back
saying No thank you and some other words
they've wanted to negotiate with me over
my property but they wanted a loaded gun
to do it they've wanted the threat of
imminent domain hanging over my head for
me to take their number instead of them
taking my number and running a business
when you're under the threat of imminent
domain is really really hard you're
looking out today tomorrow
a month from now but you're also looking
out five and ten years out to see what
you need and not knowing whether the
government was going to come in and take
it at any at any moment I'm really kind
of defeated the whole Joy I had about
thinking about the future of this place
and developing 10-year strategies I've
never been in the way of what they
wanted to do so I would say how could I
be in the way of something when I've
told them I would sell to them from day
one they just never have wanted to meet
me even close to my price that's the
government saying we don't have to
because we can Emma domain you instead